bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaires seller de
parlement hebdo avec o2 moracchini
bonjour et dans l'actualité cette
semaine paris et berlin sur la même
longueur d'onde politique célébration
grandes courbes du 50e anniversaire du
traité d'amitié franco-allemand 400
députés des sénateurs tous rassemblés à
berlin pour écouter le couple angela
merkel françois hollande unis contre le
mariage pour tous les députés ump sein
de l'écharpé tricolore ont marché cette
semaine sur l'elysée pour demander à
être reçu par françois hollande
veillée d'armes avant d'attaquer les
débats dans l'hémicycle début mardi
prochain pour 15 jours qui s'annoncent
animés enfin c'est l'image de cette fin
de semaine florence cassez libérer sept
ans passés dans les geôles mexicaines à
son arrivée à paris elle a rendu hommage
à nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande
pour avoir oeuvré à sa libération est
avec nous pour commenter l'actualité
françois de rugy bonjour avec moi sur ce
plateau est député de loire-atlantique
et co président du groupe écologiste à
l'assemblée là est ce qu'on doit dire
qu'au président parce qu'il se trouve
que l'assemblée ne veut pas d'une
coprésidence ce n'est pas dans le
règlement et que pour l'instant ce
serait plutôt barbara pompili qui serait
présidente
mais il faut dire qu'au président c'est
comme ça que nous le concevons elle et
moi et l'ensemble de notre groupe nous
avons souhaité faire cela déjà depuis le
mois de juin dernier
donc l'assemblée ne le reconnaît pas
officiellement on va proposer une
réforme du règlement depuis la fin du
mois de janvier le 31 janvier et puis on
verra si c'est adopter nous le
souhaitons pas ce que je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est assez souple
asselah vous voulez un homme une femme
oui tout à fait proposez-vous leur n'est
pas obligatoire cvo londres- pause qu'il
puisse y avoir une coprésidence me ciel
a lieu on souhaite qu'elles soient
paritaire et si c'est rejeter qui est
président ou précédent eh bien on le
fera à tour de rôle jeux l'été pendant
les six premiers mois du mandat barbara
pompili a commencé depuis le 14 janvier
présidente et elle est la première dans
l'histoire de la vème république à ma
connaissance la présidente
d'un groupe parlementaire et le pouvoir
c'est mieux à deux je pense que c'est
une bonne façon à la fois d'afficher
clairement la parité nous sommes le seul
groupe à l'assemblée nationale qui
compte autant de députés
et est-ce que deux députés et es1 nous
sommes les seuls c'est ainsi et alors
que rien n'oblige dans la loi avoir la
parité aux législatives
et puis nous avons vu en allemagne
puisqu'on parlait de l'allemagne que ça
se pratique depuis longtemps les faire
le pratiquer en allemagne on va voir que
le modèle allemand vous vous plaît
beaucoup à bien des égards alors c'est
la règle on a demandé à vos collègues ce
qu'ils pensent de vous et on va
évidemment demander en premier à barbara
pompili et c'est françois slama qui a
posé la question en quatre colonnes
françois de rugy c'est un passionné de
politique et ça fait très longtemps
qu'il est donc forcément en tant que
député on le voit qui est investi sur
énormément de sujets d'ailleurs il a
impressionnant parce qu'il a un avis sur
tout donc
il est il nous aide beaucoup c'est un
très bon qu'au président de groupe c'est
un esprit à ses fins voilà c'est
quelqu'un de cultivé quelqu'un qui a des
convictions bastonnant intelligent et il
n'est pas prétentieux c'est je pense un
des meilleurs de la nouvelle génération
des hommes politiques qu'on serait pas
forcément la même chose de françois de
rugy en tant qu'homme et en tant que
député en tant qu'homme il est plutôt
éminemment sympathique plutôt ouvert est
quelqu'un avec qui on peut discuter sans
aucune difficulté
mais dès qu'il ya une caméra décoder
dans l'hémicycle là monsieur de rugy
devient véritablement rugissants et là
il devient souvent un peu caricatural un
peu systématique et un peu manichéen et
donc l'homme et le parlementaire s'est
pas tout à fait la même chose
vous reconnaissez un petit peu dans ce
que dit benoît paré ou pas du tout je
pourrais lui renvoyer le complément
assez facilement ce type de la politique
il faut que c'est un petit peu
caricatural sens qu'il dit parce que
s'il a suivi réellement ce que j'ai fait
partant dans le précédent mandat où
j'étais dans l'opposition
je crois avoir montré à certaines
reprises j'ai voté pour le grenelle de
l'environnement j'ai voté pour certaines
moi j'ai voté pour un accord social qui
avait été à l'époque fait par les
partenaires sociaux j'étais le seul à
gauche l'avoir fait mais je ne le
regrette pas du tout alors sans
caricaturer sans rougir on va faire
ensemble cette émission on va commencer
avec le voyage parlementaire de la
semaine direction berlin pour les noces
d'or france allemagne
alors nous sommes mardi à l'occasion des
50 ans du traité de l'élysée une partie
du gouvernement quelques 400 députés et
des sénateurs font voyage à berlin avec
en point d'orgue la séance du bundestag
où les députés allemands sont seize se
sont serrés pour vous faire de la place
récit de la séance avec rim benameur la
scène fera date parlementaires allemands
et français réunis au bundestag
toute une organisation 400
parlementaires français présents du
front de gauche au front national en
passant par l'ump le ps
des chaises ont donc été rajoutés
placement libre
excepté pour le premier rang cinquante
ans jour pour jour après la signature
par de gaulle et adenauer du traité de
l'elysée les présidents d'assemblée
n'ont qu'un mot à la bouche
historique que de chemin parcouru
ensemble
que d'obstacles franchi de prétendus
fatalité éviter de mauvaises destinée et
ce qu'il veut ceux qui ont conscience de
la signification de ces cinquante
dernières années de l'histoire
européenne ne peuvent pas considérer que
cette conséquent le commémoration n'est
qu'un chiffre rond un événement
quelconque même discours mêmes émotions
pour le chef de l'état français je
mesure le moment exceptionnel que nous
vivons et le privilège qui m'est donnée
de m'exprimer ici au nom de la france au
bundestag angela merkel prend la parole
et provoque une salve d'applaudissements
lorsqu'elle évoque le mali l'allemagne
est aux côtés de la france pour ce qui
est de la mission au mali
voilà pourquoi nous soutenons la france
puis tour à tour les présidents de
groupes des deux pays se succèdent à la
tribune bruno le roux se démarque c'est
le premier à se lancer dans la langue de
goethe zerg herter ère pré village
libre connaît des mêmes ou une collègue
à la chancelière approuve 2h30 de
discours et une fin de session
parlementaire toute trouvée la
marseillaise résonne en plein coeur du
bundestag
voilà françois de rugy vous étiez
également dans cet hémicycle à berlin
avec vos collègues qui visiblement ont
apprécié l'expérience vous proposant
d'écouter certains d'entre eux j'étais
côte à côte avec un un collègue allemand
qui est né un an avant moi donc en 63
qui donc était très ému parce qu'il me
racontait que son père était avait fait
la guerre son grand père avait fait la
guerre et qu'il était la première
génération à ne pas être en guerre il
était vraiment très ému et je partageais
cette émotion parce qu'en fait ce sont
les destins croisés de deux nations
depuis des siècles et des siècles et je
trouve que c'est un moment très émouvant
aujourd'hui je crois que nous avons
chacun nos particularités notre histoire
notre culture notre manière de voir les
choses
aujourd'hui la france et l'allemagne
celle épine dorsale de l'union
européenne même si elle est à 27
et c'est une façon quand même pour
beaucoup de parlementaires de comprendre
l'importance de cette relation entre la
france et l'allemagne
alors bon historique ou une très belle
image pour l'histoire c'est surtout un
anniversaire important moment historique
je ne crois pas parce qu a pas eu de
grandes annonces ya pas eu de 2,2
discours très marquants comme il y avait
pu avoir françois mitterrand par exemple
ou ne stagne dans les années 80 c'est
assez rare d'ailleurs qu'un chef d'état
étranger s'exprime devant le bundestag
en revanche c'est un moment intéressant
en tout cas pour nous français moi j'ai
trouvé que c'était très intéressant par
les échanges qu'on a pu avoir avec nos
collègues derrière eux sortie finale
bourde de très spécifiques
les pasdarans ce nom mais la
construction européenne est en crise le
couple franco allemand n'est plus ce
qu'il était en quelque sorte ça c'est
une réalité et elle n'a pas été changée
bouleversé simplement parce qu'on se
réunissaient dans le même parlement le
symbole était intéressant quand même que
les deux parlements pas simplement qu'un
chef d'état français s'exprime devant le
parlement allemand mais que les deux
parlements siège temps semble ça je
trouve le symbole très intéressant mais
il sera d'autant plus fort qu'il
débouchera sur quelque chose dans les
années
on a entendu un gars la marque elle
parlait du mali vous même vous êtes
partie de la commission de la défense
contrairement à noël mamère et approuvé
l'intervention au mali ce que vous avez
senti pendant votre voyage à berlin
qu'il y avait une réelle volonté la
chancelière d'impulser une action
européenne
j'ai senti deux choses d'abord les
allemands il faut le savoir sont
quasiment en campagne électorale
puisqu'il va y avoir des élections
législatives au mois de septembre
prochain
donc en allemagne l'engagement de
troupes allemandes dans des conflits
extérieurs est assez peu populaire il
faut bien dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont nos homologues nous l'ont
dit donc toutes les forces politiques
allemands sont très prudentes par
rapport à l'engagement allemand en
revanche avoir un engagement plus fort
là nos homologues vers nous l'ont dit
ils souhaitent ils interpellent la
chancelière d'ailleurs pour qu'il y ait
un engagement au delà de ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
du point de vue logistique sas a déjà
commencé mais de façon plus en plus de
plus amples et puis aussi du point de
vue humanitaire du point de vue de
l'information cologie sera pour ville
soutient l'intervention médiation avait
peu de chances pour que les halles
morgenster à l'heure actuelle je pense
que compte tenu du fait qu'il y ait des
élections 27 ans est assez peu probable
dans l'immédiat oui alors en tant que
co-président de groupe peuvent vous êtes
exprimés vous même à la tribune aux
mêmes parler en allemand dans un bel
allemand semble-t-il une langue que
visiblement vous maîtrisez bien vous
avez quand même poursuivi en français
comme vous aviez trois minutes seulement
vous en êtes venu à l'essentiel à savoir
notamment la fiscalité écologiste en
écoute
mesdames et messieurs les députés du
bundestag
nous voulons d'abord vous dire qu en
confirmant récemment le choix de sortie
du nucléaire vous avez fait un bon choix
nos différences dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres
peuvent être des forces les compétences
acquises par les uns seront utiles aux
autres écologie fonctionnement
institutionnel plus parlementaire
culture de la négociation et du
compromis social pour les écologistes
si l'allemagne n'ont pas un modèle à
copier elle est une référence dont les
pouvant souvent nous inspirer et nous
enrichir et pour notre part nous le
revendiquons alors françois de rugy si
l'allemagne n'est pas un modèle pour
vous ça y ressemble quand même
terriblement
je crois que c'est une source
d'inspiration pour les écologistes à
vous étonnera peut-être pas beaucoup
les allemands ont ouvert la voie de
l'écologie politique
vous savez qu au bundestag il ya un
groupe écologiste depuis 30 ans cette
année trente ans nous ça fait 6 mois
donc ils ont un peu d'avancé sur mais
bon faut bien le reconnaître pour autant
moi je ne suis pas du tout dans la
logique en effet du modèle à copier
parce que je crois que chaque pays a son
histoire
mais en revanche on peut s'enrichir
mutuellement c'est souvent alors dans
ces cas-là une banalité que de le dire
mais c'est une réalité et j'ai cité des
exemples au contrôle parlementaire vous
enviez le pouvoir de la députée avec le
président du groupe du parti auquel
appartient la merkel a dit dans son
intervention
nous tenons particulièrement à ce que
madame merkel la chancelière qui le
soutient respecte le fait que c'est le
gros parlementaire qui a le dernier mot
il l'a dit à la tribune il est à dire
indirectement à françois hollande en
disant vous savez quand madame merkel
vous dit qu'elle doit tenir compte du
parlement
ce n'est pas une figure de style et nous
y tenons ça fait rêver mais je crois que
c'est une démocratie qui est plus
avancée du point de vue parlementaire
que nous et jean françois copé qui a dit
à berlin
il reproche à françois hollande est un
petit peu l'auteur de la dégradation du
couple franco-allemand pour vous c'est
quoi ces déplacés où j'ai totalement
déplacé d'autant plus que les
gesticulations
je n'étais pas du tout le moment mais
même nom mais moi ça me gêne pas qu'on
fasse de la politique savez moi j'ai dit
un certain nombre de choses je pense que
ça sert à rien de faire de la langue de
bois parce qu'on est dans un
anniversaire
mais au-delà de cela nicolas sarkozy
avec ses gesticulations permanente
pendant cinq ans je crois qu'il n'a pas
fait grand chose pour renforcer le
couple franco allemand à la fin
il a été très suiviste vis-à-vis de
madame merkel mais au départ il a voulu
jouer cavalier seul et moi je les dis le
cavalier seul la tentation du cavalier
seul c'est la pire des choses
des deux côtés parce qu'on sait qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui fortement en
allemagne
voilà encore un petit peu de l'europe
vous avez peut-être aussi suivi au même
moment ce qui se passait en angleterre
qui demande un référendum éventuellement
2010 cette formation sort de l'europe ou
pas qu'est ce que vous en pensez bien
que la politique de l'apartheid ron mais
c'est peut-être bien qu'on aille faire
une session commune à la chambre
d'économie justement jamais sa passion
en périgord mais plus sérieusement
moi je vais vous dire deux choses sur la
grande bretagne que la grande bretagne
doit faire un référendum pourquoi pas
après tout la grande bretagne arrête pas
de nous faire le chantage à la sortie de
l'union européenne
moi je trouverais ça mieux qu'il y ait
un référent par ailleurs jeudi avoir à
l'union européenne sans la boîte coule
douce en provoquant lorsque cameron a
fait cette annonce jeudi à la limite
pourvu que les britanniques votent non
au maintien de la grande-bretagne
européenne parce que je crois que mes
modèles britannique de la construction
open est un modèle mortifère kühl qui
d'ailleurs est en train de se mettre en
place c'est à dire une simple zone de
libre échange et surtout ce que nous
devons dire à david cameron et françois
hollande l'a fait fermement et là tout à
fait raison c'est qu'il est hors de
question on renégocie quoi que ce soit
avant ce référendum
c'est référendum deux principes sur le
maintien ou non de la grande bretagne
dans l'union européenne point la ligne
moi je voudrais vous proposer une image
on va reparler de la france et de
l'allemagne
vous savez toujours que cette affaire de
symbole évidemment ce rappel de françois
mitterrand et d'helmut kohl main dans la
main elle a cette fois c'est françois
hollande et en monyela merkel une bise
oui mais très timide avec eux ça a été
au début très rugueux et puis c'est
devenu au fil du temps peut-être un
petit peu plus sérieux je courais
difficile au départ merkel nous l'avons
vu vous avez mangé inter je suis
intervenu en étant face à l'inde à
merkel et un françois hollande
merkel est un animal de sang froid 1 ce
n'est pas quelqu'un de très expressif
c'est indéniable donc je crois qu'il
faut respecter sur la réserve également
quelqu'un de beaucoup moins extraverti
que ne l'était son prédécesseur
moi je trouve que ça peut faire que des
clés vous savez les relations franco
allemandes elles se sont jamais
construite
immédiatement on parlait de radés naouar
et charles de gaulle ils ont signé ce
traité en 1963 adenauer a été chancelier
depuis longtemps et charles de gaulle
était président de la vue depuis cinq
ans helmut kohl et françois mitterrand
au début commencé on avait dit que voilà
et on avait dit notamment parce qu'il
faut se rappeler qu'elle me colle a
succédé un chancelier social-démocrate
que françois mitterrand avait connu au
départ lequel chance et social démocrate
s'entendait bien et valéry giscard
d'estaing réponse qu'on est obligé de
condamnés à s'entendre finalement ils
n'ont pas le choix
avais je crois en effet que l'allemagne
et la france si on veut faire progresser
la construction open doivent absolument
s'entendre m'importe c'est ce que j'ai
dit d'ailleurs ce qu'on se dise tu ou
qu'on se fasse la bise mène de loi oui
ou que comme me l'avait dit ce matin
nicolas sarkozy monsieur merkel en
parlant du mari d'angela merkel qui ne
porte pas ce moment là allez va passer
au mercredi
c'est la grogne des profs allez on ce
mercredi les enseignants du primaire se
mobilisent vincent peillon à propose
présentant conseil des missions projet
de refondation de l'école au milieu de
mesures très consciencieux il y en a
d'autres qui le sont beaucoup moins
comme bien sûr la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
dans l'après-midi la contestation passe
de la rue à l'assemblée pierre lascars
la grogne des professeurs des écoles
s'est poursuivie aujourd'hui il n'était
certes pas plus de 2000 dans la rue mais
toujours insatisfait par le manque de
concertation
je l'aï fait ce cotre une réforme qui se
fait
essentiellement la va vite ça fait huit
mois qu'ils sont là et on a déjà une
réforme qui nous tombe tout cuit
sauverait véritable consultation 101
sans prendre le temps de mettre les
choses bien à plat de consulter tout le
monde
si la réforme voulue par le gouvernement
permettrait de créer 60 mille postes
d'enseignants la problématique du rythme
scolaire reste un sujet de discorde
mais pour les syndicats pas question
d'accepter les accusations de
corporatisme
nous n'avons jamais fait différence
entre les conditions de travail des
maîtres et les conditions d'enseignement
pour les élèves
nous ne pensons que s'il n'y avait pas
les statuts des personnels il ya bien
longtemps que l'école publique et serait
par terre
donc en défendant nos statuts nos
conditions de travail nous avons la
ferme conviction de défendre l'école la
réforme de l'éducation s'est aussi
invitée dans l'hémicycle cet après midi
le camion pour le gouvernement
d'affirmer sa volonté d'aboutir sur le
sujet pour les professeurs et pour les
collectivités territoriales
il y aura une nécessité de s'adapter
mais cette réforme est indispensable
parce qu'elle est dans l'intérêt de nos
enfants nos enfants sont maltraités
parmi tous les enfants d'anne ocde ils
sont celles qui ont le moins de jours de
classe
144 jours alors que 187 jours pour les
autres enfants
par conséquent il faut impérativement
que les choses évoluent au delà du rire
c'est sur la méthode du ministre de
l'éducation que l'ump se montre très
critique
on est sur une réforme a préparé avec un
ministre qui qui n'écoutent pas nous on
était
habitué à l'arrogance et la suffisance
de monsieur peillon mais je pense que
d'autres sont en train de le découvrir
aujourd'hui notamment les enseignes
aujourd'hui la traduction législative de
la réforme de l'éducation restent encore
floues mais les syndicats ont d'ores et
déjà prévenu il y aura d'autres journées
d'action en soi un doji vous aviez des
parents enseignants vous pour ckoi que
cette contestation sur les rythmes
scolaires notamment
elle ne m'étonne pas beaucoup parce que
la grosse erreur ça a été de supprimer
l'école le samedi matin sans basculer
immédiatement sur le mercredi matin moi
je l'avais dit à l'époque
ah oui tout à fait je soutiens cette
réforme je pense qu'elle est elle est
très importante savez je vous disais je
suis fils et petit fils d'enseignant
mais je suis aussi parents d'élèves et
donc je connais aussi l'école par le
biais des élèves et je vois aujourd'hui
une école concentrer sur quatre jours ce
n'est pas une bonne chose et ce serait
l'intérêt de tout le monde d'avoir une
demi journée le mercredi matin
après il faut négocier c'est normal les
enseignants ne vont pas accepter comme
cela c'est normal ce changement et les
attaques canton 10e c'est du
corporatisme il reste finalement bloquée
on peut absolument pas réformer l'école
c'est possible sur selon vous moi je
crois justement que si on négocie ici on
discute et qu'on fait preuve de
détermination on y arrive
oui va sans payer audi je leur ai donné
soixante mille soixante mille places
finalement on va créer 60000 places et
aujourd'hui on m'attaque encore une fois
dans la rue
oui mais c'est nous nous avons discuté
avec vincent peillon il ya quelques
semaines et nous étions bien conscients
de ces difficultés et on ne va pas faire
ces changements là sans qu' il y ait un
minimum de discussions dont de
contestation parce qu'il ya une culture
syndicale aussi dans l'éducation
nationale
mais pour autant je crois que quand il
ya eu la suppression du samedi matin les
enseignants étaient massivement contre
il était contre alors qu'ils auraient pu
se satisfaire d'avoir une demi journée
d'enseignement en moins en plus les
enseignants n'avaient pas de week-end
plein ils ont obtenu cela on bat là je
crois qu'il faut travailler à ce
basculement vers le mercredi matin c'est
un émissaire est plus difficile en fait
mystère parce que c'est le ministère où
il ya le plus de
d'agents de plus de fonctionnaires donc
dès que vous prenez une mesure ça
immédiatement des conséquences énormes
en termes budgétaires il faut que les
gens comprennent ça dès que vous dites
on va faire deux heures de formation en
plus c'est comme si vous supprimez d'un
seul coup plusieurs milliers de postes
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement lourd à gérer mais moi je
crois que vincent peillon il a la bonne
le bon discours et la bonne attitude
contrairement à ce qui était dit dans le
replantage aller mercredi toujours on va
parler de mercaptan c'est le nombre de
ce gaz qui s'échappe depuis la veille
d'une usine de rouen et dont l'odeur se
fait sentir jusqu'à paris et même dans
le sud de l'angleterre à la sortie du
conseil des ministres delphine batho en
charge de l'environnement fait une
déclaration en coûte une gêne c'est un
gaz vraiment qui sent très très mauvais
certaines personnes ont pu ressentir des
maux de tête ou bien des nausées ce sont
des symptômes passagers il n'y a pas de
danger pour la santé du fait de ses
émanations de gaz je vais très très
clair et très précises sur ce point
c'est normal de rechercher les causes de
cette pollution et donc il y aura bien
sûr à la fois une enquête administrative
est aussi une enquête judiciaire pour
établir l'origine de cette fuite de gaz
et les responsabilités bien sûr donc est
ce que vous croyez belchim bateau ce
qu'on peut dire que ce gaz était
inoffensif mais très odorant et je pense
qu'en france on a une mauvaise gestion
des risques et là on en voit encore
malheureusement l'illustration parce que
d'abord les gens ont été prévenus de
façon très sporadique senti cet
ascenseur du matin ont été réveillés à
la personne par twitter c'est un eu des
messages pas de message officiel pendant
longtemps puis un message officiel
difficile à appréhender c'est quand même
normal quand on vous dit attention à
protéger les plus fragiles
oui vous pouvez avoir des maux de tête
des nausées mais non il n'y a pas de
problème de santé des maux de tête et
des nausées c'est ce qu'on aura une
crainte est donc là on voit bien que
malgré d'autres catastrophes par le
passé mon l'a heureusement
visiblement il n'y aura pas d'effet
à moyen et long terme tant mieux sur un
site classé seveso oui voilà et ça c'est
quand même un problème qui n'est pas
davantage y compris d'exercice nous on a
toujours plaidé pour la transparence la
plus totale parce que dès qu il ya un
manque de transparence
il ya du soupçon et puis il faut que les
habitants les riverains hills et les
moyens avec des exercices préalable de
réagir ne bien réagir en cas de dallaire
parce que ça peut toujours arriver j'ai
l'impression qu'en france on préfère
continuer dans la logique de l'autruche
ni le risque
et puis lorsqu'il arrive on est
complètement déçus pour préconiser
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait mettre en place
justement pour éviter ce genre de
désagrément pas de l'usiné évidemment
mais faire des tests supplémentaires
mais des alertes faire des exercices
c'est ça oui je pense qu'il faut avoir
alors y compris des protections pour les
habitations et c'est parce que dans les
plans de prévention des risques
il y a parfois des dispositifs qui ne
sont pas activés y compris aux des
dispositifs financiers pour aider les
habitations ce que par exemple s'il faut
que les habitations puisse s'isoler il
faut qu'on finance des travaux dans les
maisons dans les logements
et puis des exercices alors une loi
peut-être mais en tout cas ce que je
crois c'est qu'il faut sortir et est
sage je souhaite que la mini c'est
compris le dise plus clairement plus
fortement de cette culture de la
négation du risque de la négation avant
et même parfois pendant et puis après on
se charge de vite étouffé les avez eu
l'occasion de discuter de tout cela avec
delphine batho depuis quelques examens
récemment nous l'avions rencontré très
peu de temps après sa nomination mais
c'était intéressant depuis
non nous avons eu des échanges sur
d'autres sujets mais je souhaite d'une
manière générale j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire qu'elle s'affirme davantage
quand on est ministre de l'écologie on
doit faire face à énormément de lobby y
compris au coeur de l'état donc il faut
s'affirmer il faut faire le bras de fer
il faut surtout pas jouer petit bras et
minimiser notre deyris mme ben je crois
qu'elle est trop prudente
vous allez faire discuter d'une
proposition loi normalement venue du
sénat remet son lieu de cils visant à
protéger les lanceurs d'alert en quoi ça
consiste
vous savez qu'il y a parfois des
personnels dans les entreprises qui
veulent attirer l'attention sur un
problème qui l'ont détecté et ce sont
parfois les gens qui travaillent dans
les entreprises qui sont les mieux
placés pour le faire ou des chercheurs
dans leurs laboratoires
le cas sur telle ou telle molécule ou
des gens avaient attiré l'attention et
puis non seulement ils n'ont pas été
écoutés mais ils ont parfois été
sanctionné donc le premier but de cette
proposition de masse et de protéger ceux
qui lancent des alertes et surtout qu'il
y ait des suites c'est pour le code du
travail ça oui ça concernant le code du
travail
bien sûr et c'est difficile là aussi on
se heurte à des résistances qui ne
viennent pas forcément de parfois de là
où on pense en fait une proposition de
loi vous avez les députés socialistes
derrière vous sur ce qu'on a discuté en
commission et là il ya eu dès lors la
figuration les amendements mais non on
travaille bien sur ce sujet là on a on
avait bien travaillé au sénat on a bien
travaillé là il y aura une nouvelle
lecture au sénat je pense qu'on va avoir
une vraie procédure législative sur ce
sujet auquel est vrai discussions avec
le parti socialiste aurait plus de vos
demandes
or ce qui concerne l'écologie il
répondre à vos demandes mais là à partir
du moment où nous nous mettons une
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour de
toutes façons on est obligé d'en
discuter mais là on a eu une discussion
très constructive et puis après lorsque
général d'assuréo est une façon plus
générale c'est difficile depuis huit
mois je vais pas vous dire que vous ne
croiriez pas si je vous disais que le
gouvernement est toujours très ouverts à
toutes les propositions écologistes mais
c'est notre rôle d'insister et les gens
peuvent être sûrs d'une chose c'est que
nous ne lâcherons pas et que là on va
rentrer dans une phase en début d'année
beaucoup plus intéressante puisqu'on a
le débat sur l'énergie qui doit se
dérouler sur ses six premiers mois on va
passer au jeudi
quand l'ump parle de famille
une convention axée sur le rôle et la
place de la famille le créneau est
plutôt porteur pour l'ump qui poursuit
là évidemment son offensive contre le
mariage pour tous des tables rondes des
sociologues tous opposés à ce mariage la
semaine prochaine à l'assemblée vous
savez que ce débat arrive dans
l'hémicycle c'est un reportage de
germain andrieu c'est le grand retour
des conventions et c'est surtout la
première à l'ump depuis l'élection
présidentielle derrière le thème de la
famille c'est bien sûr le mariage pour
tous qui est au centre des débats
l'objectif de l'ump reprend l'offensive
médiatique tout en affichant les
différentes sensibilités
en clair éviter toute caricature en
laissant la parole aux pros et aux anti
mariage pour tous
même si les anti restent majoritaires
c'est un débat qui est ouvert
oui bien sûr
mais la position de l'ump majoritaire
est clair mais la grande différence avec
le ps c'est que il ya liberté de vote
à l'ump on n'est pas là pour faire une
quelconque prosélytisme en disant il
faut impérativement au tessin sont des
sujets très personnel qui engagent des
réflexions très personnel chacun fait ce
qu'ils veulent en la matière et au moins
nous débattons est tout de même il ya
quelque chose qui est très fort à l'ump
c'est que nous sommes libres nous sommes
libres de nos convictions nous sommes
libres de leur expression nous sommes
libres de nos débats nous sommes libres
de nos votes
tout l'enjeu pour l'opposition est de
roder ses arguments à quelques jours
d'une mobilisation en faveur du mariage
pour tous et surtout avant l'examen du
texte à l'assemblée mardi prochain alors
on va parler un peu longuement c'est
bien sûr l'un des temps forts de cette
année parlementaire qui s'ouvre le
mariage pour tous arrivent dans
l'hémicycle donc mardi on va en parler
avec une députée qui va monter au front
pendant ces deux semaines et c'est le
plus de l'hebdo corinne narassiguin
bonjour je vous êtes député socialiste
chargé par votre groupe de suivre ce
texte aux côtés du rapporteur erwann
binet voulait donc être amenés à
intervenir dans l'hémicycle alors comme
lui vous êtes une députés fraîchement
élus une nouvelle députée on peut dire
est ce que vous craignez un petit peu
ces débats dans l'hémicycle qui vont
être agitées avec les parlementaires ump
souvent aguerri sur la question je pense
qu'on a déjà vu pas mal de confrontation
en commission des lois moi j'ai près de
sable ça vous a servi de banc d'essai
voilà là c'est sûr ce sera beaucoup plus
dur en hémicycle et puis ça durera plus
longtemps
combien d'amendements déposés dans le
texte s'est pas encore fait puisque
c'est ce sera c'est la date limite c'est
ce soir je crois dernier compteur on
était à peu près 4000 ha oui quand même
ça va être une vraie bataille
parlementaire français d'origine où je
vois je vois un peu
ces hommes sont assez libres par rapport
à cette question de l'obstruction
parlementaire puisque dans le précédent
mandat j'étais dans l'opposition et j'ai
toujours refusé avec mes collègues
écologistes on n'a jamais déposé ces
centaines ou des milliers d'amendements
chaîne est réservé un pull là sur ce
projet va déposer une dizaine dont il
s'assure vraiment oui quelque chose de
constructif et puis à quelques débats
qui doivent être posées qui ne seront
sans doute pas tranché à cette occasion
comme la question de la procréation
médicalement assistée mais que l'on
voulait poser par le biais d'amendements
varlet corée corée racing notamment sur
ses quatre mille amendements ont été
déposés
évidemment beaucoup on imagine par
l'opposition vous êtes prête vous à
cette bataille parlementaire qui va
arriver jour nuit week-end compris
oui oui on y est préparé on prend des
vitamines et on a prévu de débattre jour
et nuit week-end compris on a prévu je
crois une plage de d'à peu près deux
semaines mais on espère que ça durera
pas aussi longtemps mais s'il faut aller
plus loin on ira plus loin au simon est
prêt alors il ya eu cependant je
voudrais dire si vous me permettez que
les gens peuvent se dire mais c'est le
folklore parlementaire on va si j'ai des
jours des nuits le week-end
moi je trouve ça ridicule et je trouve
ça même choquant dans la période
actuelle que l'ump choisissent de faire
cela sur ce sujet là alors que les gens
aimeraient bien que l'on puisse pas
régler ce problème là mais passer aussi
à d'autres sujets sur l'emploi sur
l'économie c'est ça les priorités
actuelles et c'est l'opposition qui va
nous entraîner qui essayent de nous
entraîner dans un débat à rallonge sur
ce sujet là pendant deux ou trois
semaines
il aurait fallu utiliser le tout ce
qu'on appelle le temps programmé c'est à
dire un printemps bien définis je ne
sais pas mais je crois qu'il ya un
moment il faudra savoir que tout le
monde prenne sa société que tous les
groupes
les arguments ont été échangés au bout
de quelques jours non absolument pas je
pense que c'est important qu'on que le
débat parlementaire ait lieu
de façon normale et qu'on passe pas en
temps programmé jeu mais oui mais je
pense que justement c'est effectivement
à l'ump de position de prendre leurs
responsabilités je crois dans les
amendements qui sont déposées il y a je
serais étonné s'il ya plus de 50 à nos
différentes devenu l'opposition ce sont
essentiellement des amendements
identiques donc c'est effectivement une
technique essentiellement d'obstruction
alors ce mercredi il ya une image qui
vous a sans doute pas échappé ce sont
ces députés ump sein de l'écharpé
tricolore qui ont marché de l'assemblée
jusqu'au palais de l'élysée on regarde
cette image pour remettre un courrier où
ils ont réclamé d'être reçu par françois
hollande ils ont finalement été reçus
par un conseiller de l'elysée des
députés ump qui se plaignent de ne pas
être écoutés qui est pas de négociation
malgré l'ampleur de la manifestation des
opposants
vous pouvez comprendre ou où on les a
c'est écoutez virgin allemand le tass
laisse entrer chez comme ça je pense
qu'ils sont ici ils sont entendus
maintenant on a un d un désaccord
fondamental et je pense que nous
considérons que leur leurs arguments ne
sont pas convaincants cette appartenance
les a pas entendus c'est donc il ya un
débat qui a lieu quand même partout et
donc on l'a aussi havrais des plaques
société finalement ils se saisissent de
ce thème pour faire un vrai choc
politique finalement pour régler aussi
quelques points lebron interne sûrement
mais c'est un vrai choix de société qui
va être débattu à l'assemblée nationale
oui mais je crois qu'il faut pas en
rajouter
en réalité quand la droite dit on n'a
pas eu de débat c'est ridicule on les a
jamais autant entendu sur ce sujet là on
al'impression d'ailleurs qu' axa qui les
intéressent que c'est véritablement dans
la rue obsessionnel oui c'est normal
mais ça fait 15 ans qu'on en parle parce
que le pacs il a été discutée et votée
il ya 15 ans et depuis 15 ans on parle
de cette évolution et il y à des débats
que ce soit sur le mariage sur
l'adoption moi je comprends j'ai reçu
les opposants dans ma circonscription
j'ai discuté avec des gens je comprends
qu'ils usent que certaines personnes
soient heurtés dans leur schéma mais
lorsque ce sera votée lorsque ce sera
adoptée que ça entrera en vigueur
je suis convaincu que dans un an dans
deux ans dans trois ans trouvera ça
ridicule d'en avoir fait cette date
années de carrière si jamais sont
souvent par facture non pas regarder les
autres pays notamment l'espagne
vous parliez du pacs se souvient de
cette bataille homérique entre cet
échange homérique entre lionel jospin et
christine boutin qui veut identifier
quelqu'un qui pourrait être la nouvelle
christine boutin de 2 cette année 2013
non je vais pas me lancer dans les
pronostics assez je crois que c'est
peut-être hervé mariton qui pour
l'instant ont pris la tête au niveau du
groupe ump
on verra comment ça se passe viboud cela
aussi qui est qui qui est plus jeune lui
qui comme vous d'ailleurs un peu mais ce
que nous voulons c'est sur le pacs est
quand même intéressant c'est que ceux
qui l'ont combattu avec une virulence
extrême il y a quinze ans en font
aujourd'hui le modèle indépassable nous
disent mais surtout pas le mariage de
nantes où les mêmes droits dans le pacs
vous voyez que les choses évoluent et
tout est très relatif en la matière en
tout cas l'ump il y en a avec qui vous
pouvez discuter c'est notamment le cas
de franck riester qui est l'un des seuls
députés ump qui va voter pour ce texte
et quand il ya débat au sein même de
l'ump avec les militants vous allez voir
c'est assez vif reportage rim banna
beurre moderne doit absolument faire en
sorte que le débat existe et il existe
au sein de l'ump en se respectant les
uns et des autres unité affichée donc
l'homme veut aussi être le porte-voix du
minorité silencieuse à droite il ya un
grand nombre d'électeurs de militants de
sympathisants qui sont favorables au
texte et qui me disent nous sommes de
droite et nous sommes bon texte
ils sont pas tous aux homosexuels alors
passez à franck riester
hervé mariton figure médiatique de la
lutte contre le mariage homosexuel je
mens
ariste sur le modèle le rexy proposées
aujourd'hui ne précise pas comment les
matériaux sexuellement ses photos nues
quand la salle une centaine de
spectateurs majoritairement de droite
est opposée au mariage pour tous
le débat est animé comment demain on
pourra expliquer à un père qui en ville
et plus et sa fille ont de l'amour
un mariage avec plusieurs femmes au nom
de l'amour comment on pourra leur dira t
on là on a dit oui au nom de l'amour une
fois et maintenant peu plus dérouillons
d'amour franck riester ne relève pas lui
qui a fait officiellement son coming out
il ya un an faut essayer de traiter par
un peu le mépris ce type de propos parce
que ce qu attendent parfois c'est les
personnes qui les prononce c'est
qu'heuliez la polémique et que cette
polémique puisse amalgamer les sujets le
débat à l'assemblée débute mardi
prochain le député défendra son opinion
à la tribune lors de la discussion
générale
c'est quand même très courageux de la
part de franck riester d'aller devant ce
débat quand ça ça connais un petit peu
absolument c'est très difficile j'ai eu
beaucoup l'occasion ces derniers mois
d'aller discuter avec des opposants est
compris dans des débats publics et quand
on fait dans son propre camp je pense
que c'est très difficile oui finalement
il ya un côté irrationnel dans ces
débats beaucoup des news il ya beaucoup
d'émotions oui parce que comme il sait
françois de rugy c'est sa touche de
manière très intime acceptant les gens
qui se font de la famille et donc il ya
des réactions qui sont qui sont très
émotionnel vous avez reçu des courriers
hostiles voire de menaces on sait qu'à
roanne moulinet on a reçu des on a reçu
beaucoup de courriers hostiles je crois
que le groupe socialiste dans son
ensemble a reçu des menaces des classes
sorte faut savoir ogives aussi l'énergie
à cenon à part celle de ne pas voter
pour moi mais des courriers oui mais
surtout ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
l'âge je crois que c'est très minorité
en tout cas moi je fais le pari que
c'est très minoritaire mais des
courriers très violent
dans leurs expressions verbales
orduriers souvent et il s'agit de
demander à d'autres collègues qui
reçoivent aussi ce genre de courrier de
jean s'est pas sans doute pas des
courriers inventé ce sont des habitants
de nantes de ma circonscription bon jeu
j'espère que ces manifestations de
violence de haine d'homophobie vont
retomber très vite parce que là toutes
les associations disent que tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge c'est n'ya que
montrent les violences homophobes un peu
partout en france et ça c'est très
inquiétant et je pense moi c'est le pari
que je fais que cette loi lorsqu'elle
sera adoptée d'ailleurs fera au
contraire retomber cela et fera reculer
faire que des gens qui y compris
aujourd'hui ils sont hostiles se
rendront compte dans quelques années que
finalement ils leurs craintes étaient
infondées ce qui s'est passé dans les
pays du monde notamment la très
catholique espagne
absolument au canada aussi au québec
notamment où c'est une culture très
catholique ça fait très longtemps ça
fait dix ans et tout va bien
il y avait aussi une raison pour
laquelle l'opposition s'est réveillé sur
ce texte c'est quand on a beaucoup parlé
de la progrès de la procréation
médicalement assistée même si
aujourd'hui elle a été retirée de ce
texte
c'était peut-être une erreur d'en parler
à ce moment là vous étiez pourra vous
coréens ont continué à être absolument
pour le principe je on est d'accord sur
le fond je pense que les sujets sont
absolument lié
simplement c'est pour des questions je
crois de s'assurer de faire les choses
de l'haleine d'un point de vue
législatif le plus solide possible à
partir du moment où le gouvernement nous
propose de faire dans un projet de loi
qui permet de le faire de manière plus
large de s'assurer que c'est une erreur
donc votre vie d'avoir comme ça dès le
premier texte parlé de la pma non parce
que justement c'était c'était absolument
une conséquence directe de permettre aux
femmes d'adopter les enfants de leur
conjointe à partir du mariage et donc
c'était une course était absolument
essentiel de soulever ces sujets c'est
justement parce qu'on a soulevé au cours
du débat du travail parlementaire qui a
été fait que le gouvernement a choisi de
le proposer dans un projet de loi qui va
venir très rapidement mais reçoit
d'orgies sur 7 sur ce poids sur la
procréation médicalement assistée
erreur ou pas d'en avoir parlé ah non
je ne crois pas du tout que c'est digne
en de toute façon on en aurait parlé
mais je crois que des façons sur un
point de vue bioéthique oui mais il faut
pas se tromper
l'opposition au mariage les quelques
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont défilé dans la rue c'est une
opposition au mariage
ce sont des personnes qui n'acceptent
pas l'idée que deux hommes deux femmes
se marient c'est ça le fond du problème
la pma vient se rajouter
et c'est vrai que la pma touche à des
questions aussi de bioéthique de même
que la gestation pour autrui dont il
n'est pas question en effet dans ce
texte
nous proposons simplement que les
enfants issus de cette conception qui
ont été calmes plus est donc faite aux
états unis ou ailleurs est un état civil
en france mais sans aller au-delà parce
que ce serait en effet ce moment là une
question de bioéthique voilà sur la
procréation médicalement assistée si
nous avons déposé un amendement je crois
que d'autres députés socialistes c'est
que je pense pas parce que il ya eu des
hésitations du groupe socialiste qui a
commencé par dire oui puis non le
gouvernement n'a jamais varié des ans ça
il faut le dire le gouvernement a
toujours été demandé que ce serait
madame taubira aussi que ce serait dans
un autre texte
bon je crois qu'il faut pas perdre de
vue l'essentiel c'est à dire que cette
réforme elle va être voté malgré tout
cette obstruction ça ne ralentira ça ne
fera que ralentir mais rien d'autre
et lorsqu'elle sera adoptée on se rendra
compte de cette avancée extrêmement
importante en termes d'égalité des
droits
raison les verts posent encore un
amendement sur la pma où je mets pas en
cause leur choix je reste je suis je
vous confirme que nous aurions déposé
l'amendement si nous n'avions pas obtenu
du gouvernement garantit sur le contenu
du projet doit famille et un calendrier
qui permet une adoption elle est
absolument sûr maintenant que dans ce
projet de loi sur la famille qui sera en
course et des mises le 27 mars il y aura
bien la pma dans ce texte
absolument
jean marc ayrault l'a confirmé il n'y a
qu'un et bien je vous propose de
terminer cette émission avec une autre
image c'est un peu l'image de cette fin
de semaine celle de la libération de
florence cassez
libéré après sept ans dans une prison
mexicaine
j'ai imaginé longtemps ce moment at elle
dit à sa descente d'avion accueillies à
roissy par le ministre des affaires
étrangères laurent fabius que vous voyez
sur ces images
elle a rendu hommage aux deux présidents
qui ont oeuvré pour sa libération
nicolas sarkozy d'une part et françois
hollande vous la voyez ici avec un large
sourire à sa descente d'avion alors on a
entendu beaucoup de polémiques pour
savoir en fait quitte qui avait la
paternité de cette libération
c'est quoi c'est une querelle des
libérateurs j'ai une querelle qui est
mal venu moi je crois qu'il faut être
très modeste dans ces cas là d un
françois hollande l'est dans son
comportement sur ce genre de sujet
depuis toujours
évidemment que ce n'est pas une personne
nicolas sarkozy lui voulait faire croire
que lui sa personne allait tout régler y
compris ça la vérité c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se sont battus moi
je vois sur les images là frédéric
cuvillier qui est ministre des
transports aujourd'hui mais qui était
député dans le précédent mandat moi je
les ai soutenus j'ai bien avec lui de
cette question et il y avait eu cette
histoire quand même absurde quand on y
repense que nicolas sarkozy avait voulu
faire une année france mexique pendant
une année on allait célébrer les
relations entre la france et le mexique
alors qu'on savait qu'il y avait ce
contentieux et au dernier moment il a
complètement changé d'avis en disant je
dédie cette année france mexique à
florence cassez est ce qui a évidemment
provoqué une réaction très hostile du
mexique qui a immédiatement tout annuler
je pense que nicolas sarkozy a contribué
dans le précédent mandat à ce que ce
sujet ne soit pas oubliée c'est
indéniable mais que là c'est sans doute
plus le changement de président au
mexique
et ils ont le courage de le reconnaître
les changements dans l'organisation de
la justice au mexique grâce à ce nouveau
président grâce à aussi des changements
la cour suprême qui ont permis cette
libération qui est heureuse et qui
permettra en plus visiblement de faire
bouger les choses y compris au mexique
corinne narassiguin vous êtes député des
français de l'étranger mais pas du tout
de cette circonscription d'amérique
latine vous
in vous êtes voyez un peu plus au nord
vous avez vécu ça comment j'ai forcément
suivi ça de très près oui je pense
qu'effectivement à partir du moment où
le mexique a reconnu qu'il y avait des
problèmes de procédure et que ça a
permis la libération de madame cassez
c'est une c'est une bonne chose pour
elle je pense que ça a eu beaucoup
d'impact très négatif sur ces dernières
années sur les relations diplomatiques
entre la france et le mexique donc je
pense que c'est une bonne chose que
cette affaire soit close bien sûr pour
la première concernée mais aussi pour
pour la france et le mexique
zigonet vous souhaiter bon courage pour
les deux semaines qui vaut qui vont
arriver merci une course il faut
simplement participer à cette émission
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine